and friends of james furlong joe richie
bennett
and david wales who were brutally killed
in reading on saturday
to assault defenseless people in a park
is not simply an act of
wickedness but abject cowardice
and we will never yield to those who
would seek to destroy our way of life
mr speaker with permission i will update
the house on the next steps in our plan
to rebuild our economy
and reopen our society
while waging our struggle against covet
19.
from the outset we have trusted in the
common sense and perseverance
of the british people and their response
has more than justified
our faith since i set out our plan
on the 11th of may we have been clear
that our cautious relaxation of the
guidance
is entirely conditional on our continued
defeat of the virus
in the first half of may nearly 69
000 people tested positive for covid19
across the uk by the first half of june
that total had fallen by nearly 70
percent
to just under 22 000. the number of new
infections
is now declining by between two and four
percent
every day four weeks ago
an average of one in 400 people in the
community
in england had covered 19.
in the first half of june this figure
was won
in 1700 we created a human shield around
the nhs
and in turn our doctors and nurses
have protected us and together
we have saved our hospitals from being
overwhelmed
on the 11th of may 1073 people were
admitted to hospital in england
wells in northern ireland with covid19
by the 20th of june this had fallen by
to 283
this pandemic has inflicted permanent
scars
and we mourn everyone we have lost
measured by a seven day rolling average
the number of daily deaths
peaked at 943
on the 14th of april on the 11th of may
it was 476 and yesterday
the rolling average stood at 130.
we've ordered over 2.2 billion
items of protective equipment from uk
based manufacturers
many of whose production lines have been
called
into being to serve this new demand
and yesterday we conducted or posted 139
659 tests bringing the total
to over 8 million and while we remain
vigilant
we do not believe there is currently
currently a risk of a second peak of
infections that might overwhelm
the nhs taking
everything together we continue
to meet our five tests
and the chief medical officers of all
four
home nations have downgraded the uk's
coveted alert level
from four to three meaning
we no longer face a virus spreading
exponentially
though it remains in general circulation
the administrations in scotland wales
and northern ireland
hold responsibility for their own
lockdown restrictions
and they will respond to the united
view of the chief medical officers at
their own pace
based on their own judgment
but all parts of the uk are now
traveling in the same direction and we
will continue to work together
to ensure that everyone in our country
gets the support
they need thanks to our progress
we can now go further and safely
ease the lockdown in england
at every stage caution
will remain our watchwork
and each step will be conditional
and reversible
mr speaker given
the significant fall in the prevalence
of the virus
we can change the two meter social
distancing rule
from the fourth of july
i know this rule effectively makes life
impossible for large parts of our
economy even without other restrictions
for example it prevents all but a
fraction
of our hospitality industry from
operating
that's why almost two weeks ago i asked
our experts to conduct a review
and i will place a summary of their
conclusions in the libraries of both
houses
this week where it is possible to keep
two meters apart
people should but where it is not
we will advise people to keep a social
distance
of one meter plus meaning
they should remain one meter apart while
taking mitigations to reduce
the risk of transmission and we are
today
publishing guidance on how business can
reduce the risk
by taking certain steps to protect
workers
and customers and these include for
instance avoiding
face-to-face seating by changing office
layouts reducing the number of people in
enclosed
spaces improving ventilation using
protective screens and
face coverings closing non-essential
social spaces providing hand-signed
sanitizer
changing shift patterns so that staff
work in set teams and of course we
already mandate face coverings on public
transport
while the experts cannot give a precise
assessment
of how much the risk is reduced
they judge these mitigations would make
one meter plus
broadly equivalent to the risk at two
meters
if those mitigations are fully
implemented
so either will be acceptable and our
guidance
will change accordingly and this
vital change enables the next stage of
our plan
to ease the lockdown and mr speaker i'm
acutely conscious
that people will ask legitimate
questions
about why certain activities are
allowed and others are not and i must
ask the house
to understand that the virus
has no interest in these debates
it's only interest it's only a ambition
is to exploit any opportunities to
recapture
ground that we might carelessly vacate
and to reinfect our communities and so
there is only one
certainty the fewer social contacts
you have the safer you will be and
my duty our duty is the government is to
guide
the british people balancing our
overriding aim of controlling the virus
against our natural desire
to bring back normal life
we cannot lift all the restrictions
at once so we have to make difficult
judgments and every step
is scrupulously weighed against
the evidence our principle
is to trust the british public to use
their common sense in the full knowledge
of the risks remembering that the more
we open up
the more vigilant we will need to be
from now on we will ask people to follow
guidance on social contact instead
of legislation in that spirit
we advise we advise that from the 4th of
july
2 households of any size should be able
to meet in any setting inside
or out that does not mean
they must always be the same to
households
it will be possible for instance to meet
one set of grandparents one weekend
the others the following weekend
but we are not we are not recommending
meetings of multiple households
indoors because of the risks of creating
greater chains of transmission
outside the guidance remains that people
from several households
can meet in groups of up to six
and it follows that two households
can also meet regardless of size
mr speaker i can tell the house that we
will also
reopen restaurants and pubs
all hospitality indoors will be limited
to table service and our guidance will
encourage
minimal staff and customer contact
we will ask businesses to help nhs test
and trace
responds to any local outbreaks by
collecting
contact details from customers as
happens
in other countries and we will work with
the sector
to make this manageable
almost as eagerly awaited as a pint will
be
a haircut particularly by me mr speaker
and so we will reopen hairdressers
with appropriate precautions including
the use of
visors we also intend to allow
some other close contact services such
as nail bars
to reopen as soon as we can when we're
confident they can operate in a
covered secure way
from the 4th of july provided
that no more than 2 households stay
together
people will be free to stay overnight in
self-contained accommodation including
hotels and bed and breakfasts
as well as campsites
as long as shared facilities are kept
clean
most leisure facilities
and tourist attractions will reopen
if they can do so safely
including outdoor gyms
and playgrounds cinemas museums
galleries theme parks and arcades
as well as libraries social clubs and
community centers
close proximity venues such as
nightclubs soft play areas
indoor gyms swimming pools and spas well
i'm afraid
need to remain closed for now
as will bowling alleys and water parks
but my right honourable friends the
business and culture secretaries will
establish
task forces with public health experts
and these sectors to help them
become coping secure and reopen as soon
as possible
we will also work with the arts industry
on specific guidance
to enable choirs orchestras
and theaters to resume live performances
as soon as possible recreation and sport
will be allowed but indoor facilities
including changing rooms and courts
will remain closed and people should
only play
close contact team sports with members
of their household mr speaker i know
that many have mourned the closure of
places of
worship and this year easter passover
and eid all occurred during the lockdown
so i'm delighted that places of worship
will be able to reopen
for prayer and services including
weddings
with a maximum of 30 people all subject
to social distancing
meanwhile our courts probation services
police stations
and other public services will
increasingly resume
face-to-face proceedings
wrap around care for school-age children
and formal child care will restart
over the summer primary and secondary
education
will recommence in september with full
attendance and those children
who can already go to school
should do so because it is safe
mr speaker mr speaker we will publish
covid secure
guidelines for every sector that is
reopening
and slowly but surely these measures
will restore a sense
of normality after the toughest
restrictions
in peacetime history we are now able to
make life easier
for people to see more of their friends
and families
and to help businesses get back on their
feet and get people
back into work but the virus
has not gone away we will continue to
monitor
the data with the joint biosecurity
center and our ever more
effective test and trace system
and i must be clear to the house that as
we have seen in other countries
there will be flare-ups
for which local measures will be needed
and we will not hesitate to apply the
brakes
and reintroduce restrictions
even at national level if required
so i urge everyone to stay alert control
the virus
and save lives let's keep washing our
hands
staying two meters apart wherever
feasible meeting mitigating
the risks at one meter where not
avoiding public transport
where possible wearing a mask when you
have to use
public transport getting tested
immediately
if you have symptoms self-isolating if
instructed
to do so by nhs test and trace
today we can say
that our long national hibernation
is beginning to come to an end and life
is returning to our streets and to our
shops
the bustle is starting to come back and
a new
but cautious optimism
is palpable but i must say to the house
it will be
all too easy for that frost
to return and that is why we will
continue to trust in the common sense
and the community spirit of the british
people
to follow this guidance to carry us
through and to see us to victory over
this virus
and i commend mr speaker this statement
to the house